اخبار الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه بايجاز
من تل ابيب اهلا بكم في اليوم ال8 من حرب
غزه عشرات الشهداء والجرحى في قصف
اسرائيلي كثيف على مختلف انحاء القطاع
والمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي بغزه يقول
للجزيره ان اكثر من 700 استشهدوا في غزه
خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه وان جثث الاف
الشهداء لا تزال تحت الانقاد ولا يستطاع
انتشالها والسلطات تعلن ارتكاب الاحتلال
مجزره جديده في مخيم
جباليا ميدانيا كتائب القسام تقول انها
قتلت عددا كبيرا من جنود الاحتلال بتفجير
عبوات في تجمع شرق جحر الديك ونفق داخله
مجموعه من قوات الاحتلال في بيت لهيا
والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط ليرتفع
عدد قتلاه منذ بدايه عمليته البريه الى
74 والمتحدث باسمه يقول ان حما تتفوق في
الميدان استمرار التصعيد الاسرائيلي في
الضفه الغربيه اربعه شهداء بنيران قوات
الاحتلال ومستوطنين اسرائيليين في مناطق
مختلفه من الضفه وقوات الاحتلال تقتحم
منزل خطيب المسجد الاقصى الشيخ عكرمه صبري
في القدس المحتله وتخط بقرار هدمه بحجه
البناء من دون ترخيص ونادي الاسير
الفلسطيني يقدر عدد المعتقلين خلال الليل
وفجر اليوم ب 60 بينهم خمس
فتيات وفي تطورات الجبهه اللبنانيه اطلاق
صواريخ من جنوب لبنان باتجاه ثكنه زبدين
وموقع الرمث الاسرائيليين في مزارع شبعه
والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن عن اصابه ثمانيه
جنود وثلاثه مدنيين واغلاق محاور طرق عده
في منطقه الجليل الاعلى على طول خط الحدود
مع لبنان الى
اللقاء
y